since we're talking about the
evolutionary history of a virus
uh let's zoom back out
and uh look at the evolution of proteins
i
i glanced at this 2010 nature paper on
the
quote ongoing expansion of the protein
universe
and then you know it kind of implies
and uh talks about that uh protein
started with a common ancestor which is
you know kind of interesting it's
interesting about like even just like
the first
organic thing that started life on earth
and from that there's now
you know what is it 3.5 billion years
later there's
not millions of proteins and they're
still evolving and that's
you know in part one of the things that
you're researching is there something
interesting to you about the evolution
of proteins from this initial ancestor
uh to today is there something beautiful
insightful about this
long story so i think you know uh if
if i were to pick a single keyword
about protein evolution i would pick
uh modularity something that we talked
about
uh in the in the beginning and that's
the fact that
the proteins are no longer considered
as you know as a sequence of letters
there are hierarchical uh complexities
in the way these proteins are organized
and uh
this complexities are actually going
beyond
the protein sequence it's actually going
all the way back to the
uh to the gene to the nucleotide
sequence
and so you know again these
protein domains they are not only
functional building blocks they are also
evolutionary building blocks
and so what we see in the sort of in the
later stages of evolution
i mean once this stable structurally and
functionally
building blocks were discovered they
essentially they
stay those domains stay as such
so that's why if you start comparing
different proteins
you will see that many of them will have
similar fragments and those fragments
will correspond to something that we
call
protein domain families and so so they
are still different because you you
still have mutations and and
and and you know the uh
you know different mutations are
attributed to
to you know diversification of the
function of this uh you know uh protein
domains
however you don't you very rarely see
um you know the the evolutionary events
that would split
this domain into fragments because and
it's
you know once you have the the the
the domain split you actually you
uh you know you can completely cancel
out its function
or at the very least you can reduce it
and that's not
you know efficient from the point of
view of the you know of the
cell functioning so so the the
the protein domain level is a very
important one
now on top of that right so
if you look at the proteins right so you
have this structural unions
and they carry out the function but then
much less is known about things that
connect this
protein domains something that we call
linkers
and those linkers are completely
flexible
you know parts of the protein that
nevertheless
carry out a lot of function it's like
little tails little heads
so so we we do have tails so they called
termini
c and and germany so these are things
right on the on
on on uh one and another ends of the
protein sequence
so they are also very important so they
they attributed to
very specific uh interactions between
the proteins
so but you're referring to the links
domains
that connect the domains and you know
apart from the just the the uh
simple perspective if you have you know
a very short domain
you have sorry a very short linker you
have two domains
next to each other they are forced to be
next to each other if you have a very
long one
you have the domains that are extremely
flexible
and they carry out a lot of sort of
spatial
reorganization right so but on top of
that right
just this linker itself because it's so
flexible
it actually can adapt to a lot of
different shapes and therefore
it's a it's a very good interactor when
it comes
to interaction between this protein and
other protein
all right so these things also evolve
you know uh
and they in a way have different
sort of laws of
the driving laws that uh underlie the
the evolution because they no longer
need to
uh to preserve certain structure
right uh unlike protein domains and so
now
on top of that you have uh something
that is
even less studied and this is something
that
uh uh attribute to to the concept of
alternative splicing so alternative
splicing so
it's a it's a very cool concept it's
something that uh
we've been fascinated about for you know
over a decade
uh in my lab and trying to do research
with that
but so you know so typically you know a
simplistic
perspective is that one gene is equal
one protein product right so you have a
gene
you know you transcribe it and and
translate it and you
it becomes a protein in reality
when we talk about uh eukaryotes
especially
sort of uh more recent eukaryotes
that are very complex the
gene is no it's no longer equal to
one protein it actually can
uh produce multiple
functionally uh you know active
protein products and each of them is
uh you know is uh called an
alternatively spliced product the reason
it happens
is that if you look at the gene it
actually has
it has also blocks and
the blocks some of which and it's
essentially it goes like this
so we have a block that will later be
translated we call it exon
then we'll have a block that is not
translated cut out
we call it intron so we have exon intron
exon intro etc etc etc right so
sometimes you can have uh you know
dozens of these
exons and introns so what happens is
during the the process when the gene is
converted to
rna we have
things that are cut out the introns that
cut out and exons that now get assembled
together
and sometimes we will throw out
some of the exons and the remaining
protein products will become still be
the same different oh different
right so now you have uh fragments of
the protein that no longer there
they were cut out with the introns
sometimes
you will essentially take one exam and
replace it with another one
right so there's some flexibility in
this process
so so that creates a whole new level of
complexity
because it's random now is it random
it's it's not random we
and and this is where i think uh now the
the appearance of this modern
single cell and before that
tissue level sequencing next generation
sequencing techniques such as rna-seq
allows us to see that this these are the
events
that often happen in response in is a
dynamic event that happens in response
to
to disease or in response to
certain developmental stage of a cell
and
and this is an incredibly complex
layer that also
undergoes i mean because it's at the
gene level right so
it undergoes certain evolution right
and uh now we have this interplay
between what's happening and what is
happening in the in the protein world
and what is happening in the in the gene
and you know rna world and for example
you know it's it's often that we see
that
the boundaries of this exons
coincide with the boundaries of the
protein domains
right so there is this you know close
interplay to that uh it's not always i
mean you know otherwise it would be too
simple right
but we do see the connection between
those
sort of machineries and obviously the
evolution
will pick up this complexity and
uh you know select for whatever is
successful
we see that complexity in play and and
makes this question you know more
complex but more exciting
you